hey Josh how are you I'm good man thank
you for joining me on a tea Canada pride
I don't know if you remember or not but
I came and interviewed you on set of the
Moody's in Montreal and I told you I did
this digital series for et Canada so I
thank you for taking the time and
chatting with me absolutely of course I
remember meeting in Montreal that was a
good time during the movies I remember
fun so of course it's good to be back
you've had a good couple years of course
with arrow orange is the new black
but we're here to talk AJ and the Queen
because it is a fabulous new show when
you read the script for that show what
got you excited to be part of it that
first scene where ruby red goes
backstage and puts the club manager
through let's call it advice into the
library let's say yeah after that first
thing Andrew C ready to redo the whole
room and they go that's why they call it
ruby red because the reason you've been
read reads you you
I just know right from there I didn't
have to get to who I was yet I just know
that I wanted to be part of it you have
to tell me I'm a huge fan of RuPaul
really what was RuPaul like to work with
what about you
white Oprah Brown I love me some Brown
working with Drew was an incredible
experience because I got to work
alongside somebody that has worked so
hard to where he's God he gets up every
day at 4:00 in the morning a man's
grinding you know he's just work his
work you know he puts nose to the ground
was kind to everybody is everybody like
we're one team because we were one theme
that was him in Michael Patrick King now
there were three incredible incredible
bosses but more than that peers that we
were putting this thing together this
funny weird adventure that you get to go
on with these villains chasing this art
with Ruby and this little kid any day it
was just it was such a fun adventure
that we have to go on and just laugh at
every case those sighs would be like oh
that was so weird
I love it you heard me say no butter no
I'm gonna lose my mind
if you went to butter the weirder the
better in my opinion but I mean listen
you had some of the most incredible
co-stars on the show and you know people
are like going crazy drag race season 12
was just announced but you had I don't
know there were so many drag queens all
not set did you have any time to hang
out with any of those queens I'm gonna
be honest with you I didn't have too
much time with so many Queen because
they were always in the scenes with
movie right there in passing in passing
I got to hang with a bunch of them and
honestly would always shine through was
how gracious they were to Ruth and how
gracious you know just chatting just all
of us excited to be there all of us
excited to be part of something that we
felt was special yeah I mean everybody
who's part of this show really should be
proud of it because it's not just a
television
you know it is representation on
television and that is just always so
important now that you've seen how these
queens transform would I mean listen you
are a very handsome man if I can say so
myself thank you
I could also see if you take away some
of this stubble you could be a very
attractive woman
I'm waiting for my chance to put on
Supino's okay I already told already
told SP castor day if we need a furnish
Maxine you know Hector and Ruby are
working on an axe I'm down you know I'm
ready I feel like you know I got I got
to do on your feet on Broadway so maybe
I have a couple for Stefan numbers in my
blood you know maybe I can break it out
I'll be ready
I think it's so important that you have
always been such a strong ally for the
lgbtq+ community where did that come
from when were you first introduced to
the queer community and why did you feel
maybe embraced by that community it's
one of those things where I felt a lot
of place as a kid you know I just I was
so loved by my family but you know I I
had my own things going on as a young
son I fell out of place for you know
whether it be my my own body issues or
whether it be just you know I feel the
feeling feeling like I didn't know quite
how to fit into the group's that was
forming at all those things that we all
go through right and I'm playing sports
and I loving sports and you know I get
to middle school this play that you can
do called The Wizard of Oz over at the
community theater I go I get to play the
lion this was in 7th 8th grade and I
call man this is so fun and of course
man I found the theater community I
found the drama community I got to high
school and and my best friend we're gay
you know and yeah and it's wild to think
about because now horse worlds are now
and I have perspective and I have my own
family and and my best friends are still
gay you know as I look back and I think
about what my friends had to go through
an 8th grade 9th grade
I didn't have the hindsight then to
understand what the revolt was really
tough yeah you know that they couldn't
talk about being who they were openly
but to me it was just then like this is
this is this is so this is I never felt
love like this before and a group of
friends I've never felt so welcomed in
the group of friends so Who am I to
think that we're not all the same well -
think that we're not all people in this
together just trying to find other
people to tell us that we're doing okay
you know that were that were that we're
doing the finances waking up every day
and I thank God that I apparently
supported me so much you know and of
course one of about my best friends to
this day I learn about their
relationships with their parents and you
can see you know what what how this all
transforms us you know just wine and
love and people around us and to me
that's what this is all about now I
teach my voice you know that you love
everybody you know you treat everybody
with kindness give them a smile shake
their hand in my heart and we all have
miss together you know and yeah and
that's what I love about our little show
is that it's out there but there's
family sitting around crying at the end
of an episode having conversations but
maybe they didn't have the day before
also exciting
you're gonna be on Katie keen it's so
much fun with them and you know when you
meet a cast that uh that they shall love
for being there they make you feel part
of it when you meet people like that
that shines through on screen and I
think that people are gonna have a lot
of fun with that show I can't wait to
watch that and Thank You Josh for being
such an awesome ally I hope we get to
catch up again in person sometime that's
a little bit even thank you for that
oh hey there if you want more LGBTQ news
and exclusive interviews click Subscribe
or watch these videos